[Music]
in a time when Marvel movies were
direct-to-video flops unreleased cult
films or whatever Howard the Duck was I
just can't resist your intense animal
magnetism the best and worst of Marvel
were on full display in the Blade
trilogy quench your thirst with three
movies of wildly different quality than
at their best could make bila stars look
cool and at their worst
make a list actors look ridiculous
that's just rude
all thanks to directors that range from
the unknown to the legendary to the
Pucci of comic book movies dark or
trip-hop one of her kids listening to
these days in three all rated black led
superhero films that the press just kind
of forgot existed okay look it's fine
you don't remember meteor man but there
were three of these feet Wesley Snipes a
badass never aging samurai who in these
films goes by the name blade I was born
ready mother he's a half vampire with
superior levels of melanin who can
withstand sunlight a signature style and
whatever one-liners Wesley Snipes had in
his head at the time catch you later
you tell him it's open season on all
games some mother is always trying to
ice skate on bill they sure are Wesley
hey sure wait what enter a
centuries-long war against the most
pathetic vampire since Twilight who
burst into flames at the slightest touch
of silver garlic or sunlight practice an
ancient one at a time fighting style
only have one master plan blades blood
is the key we're going to harvest your
blood what is this place it's a blood
farming facility can't really speak
through their fangs yes and name
everything by slapping the word vampire
in front of a noun vampire a vampire
cattle brand vampire vampire Bible
vampire rank-sum foundation vampire blue
Sam Puckett an avoider vibrators vampire
race that part trailer competitive
vampire gee you made a goddamn vampire
Pomeranian
that's not just lazy that's vampire lazy
thrill at an action franchise with a
unique look that an abandoned to look as
much like the matrix as possible full of
early 2000s Club raised leather trench
coats and CGI that was looking so rough
they bailed on it before the final cut
are we having fun yet played
I sure hope good call so relive the
groundbreaking superhero trilogy with
more first than you can shake a steak at
like marbles first movie franchise the
first black superhero movie franchise
Ryan Reynolds for smartass comic book
roll the first Marvel hallway fight
scene the first Marvel franchise to have
a solid origin story and even better
sequel then go off the rails in the
third one and the first franchise to
include the phrase juggling thunder
juggling thunder yeah I'm gonna bet
that's one record they won't be broken
look into you Deadpool 2 starring white
man can't slay sup dynasty vampire
weekend Daryl what are you doing here
frat pool where's his busy pee hell boys
- man I've got to character appropriate
words for you feel the driver techno
[Music]
vampires throwing children in play and
then running away
and Hot Topic you sell them merchandise
you know look around I might having
fewer things what he slew in the shadows
for everything awful about blade Trinity
it still gave us some of the best
behind-the-scenes stories of all time we
were in Vancouver and Wesley Snipes was
going crazy he would only answer to the
name blade he would communicate with
with post-its that he would give to the
director and each one he would sign
blade let's talk about it
balderdash you're a neo maxi zoom dweeby
don't dab on the haters I once stepped
on a Lego and only cried for 20 minutes